that's why this [ __ ] is crazy with the
Celtics coach yo that story she's
getting more and more my man is a wild
boy yeah well so at first I was like
kind of I wouldn't say on the side but
I'm just like nah it's foul to fire him
if it was a consensual situation fire
him initially right it was like cut it
out yeah they were like
like was like Joey
and they were just everybody was just
like yo just chill out with the [ __ ]
they were letting it Rock but then my
boy was a wild boy out here and he's
like nah you gotta go so what are the
most recent details I saw he was sending
he was making a lot of women
uncomfortable and inappropriate comments
inappropriate messages I think and the
woman one of the women he had a
long-term relationship with was also
helping me along [ __ ] move to Boston
his wife no he he would she would handle
the flights for the team that was one of
the things that she was doing so part of
that is flying the family which is he
made his fiance yeah but this is also
Boston and any news that comes out of
there like they know how to make
somebody look like [ __ ] yeah it's like
what do you mean why boss like Boston
Sports medium oh let's go to every
single female staff member and be like
have has he ever made you feel we need
you out of here
so I didn't know that yeah Boston media
is crazy perfect
like for Boston like yes it's like
Russia yeah you know what I mean it's
like the only thing getting out is
exactly what we want out to make us look
the best yeah and uh but yeah it's still
it's crazy because I think he was
smashing
the uh who's the [ __ ] uh Brad Stevens
who was the coach and is now I believe
the president of the team I think he's a
people the GM VP whatever it is uh I
think Danny Ainge is probably the
president Angie's with Utah now oh
that's okay so maybe he's the new
whatever it doesn't matter he's front
office role I think he was smashing his
assistant
and it's just like buddy what do you
[ __ ] do like that's gotta be sex
addiction right or power power
but sex addiction gotta be power
addiction too right like you know what I
think yeah I think yeah I think
addiction manifests itself in weird ways
and it's just like is he really need to
get the nut off or is he just like you
know you I'm gonna I'm gonna [ __ ] your
assistant bro yeah you know what I mean
like yeah this guy I bet there's even
Wilder [ __ ] that we don't know about
because if these are the girls like is
this right remember when Adam Levine
came out and then four more [ __ ] were
like yeah he was doing this with me too
yeah it's like we got like one or two
hmm if you do it with two why stop
yeah if you're willing to roll the dice
and throw it all away yeah yeah yeah
yeah it's probably way more and it's
just crazy I mean this guy had
everything
he hit he had a good career in the sense
that like he always had a team he in
this first [ __ ] year took the Celtic
to the finals wife Nia Long she's
wearing your [ __ ] jerseys rooting for
your team and then you're just out here
trying to [ __ ] everyone on the team I I
don't want to go crazy conspiracy but I
think that
I think a lot more people knew about
this
oh God and I think outside of just the
Celtics organization yeah oh you think
so and the reason I think is because you
have a first year black head coach that
is doing incredible things yeah
goes to the finals in Boston right with
a major team Boston sellers are major
NBA franchise and this is the first time
I've even seen this guy's name yeah like
usually this is a story that the league
goes hey put some gas on this this is
what we need this is a great opportunity
right like this is one of the things
you're most virtue single about
especially a historic franchise like the
Celtics which is damn I [ __ ]
could say racist the city of Boston
doesn't have the best reputation I mean
Lebron called them out last year exactly
LeBron now the organization I mean they
have Bill Russell and Bill Russell
became head coach like this red Arabic
made him the first black head coach
first blackhead coach right like it
obviously earned one of the greatest
players ever but still so the
organization itself maybe you could say
hasn't been super racist but still an
awesome opportunity for the league and
the Celtics to go here's our Golden
Goose
the fact that that never happened that a
lot of people are finding out this guy's
name for the first time right now yeah
to me says maybe it was one of those
[ __ ] things where it's like the HR
people are going yo he's a kind of wild
boy so we're going to look the other way
and we're not gonna make him the the
pride and joy Brad Stevens was the
[ __ ] pride and joy a lot of love if
you watch but not like you would think
in the in the song his name make it to
y'all genius coach oh my God he's so
brilliant and look at what his play
calling is here like what this is this
this story especially if they won they
came very close to winning if they were
a little older they would have won but
it would have been a [ __ ] movie it
was like out of every movie first black
head coach first year they start off not
good they're like really struggling
they're thinking about trading Jalen
Brown and then all of a sudden they just
turned it around it was like [ __ ]
Hoosiers and then they just went on this
crazy tear the back half of the season
but I think I think they knew bro so
what happens I think it's also harder to
say his name so people kind of before I
say
yeah we haven't said it one time
oh that's that's the Celtics coach
it's not as hard
all right all right Brad Stevens is
scared
she was hit different did he do anything
illegal I can't believe other than like
feminine names no this guy a wild boy
no I don't think he did anything illegal
he did something that maybe was against
the rules for the organization company
policy whatever he can't go to jail or
nothing that's not what you're not being
accused of assault or anything no no no
no he's just smashing everything yeah
I'm like what an idiot yeah like you
have to be a [ __ ] monumentally dumb
guy or addicted
to be able to kind of [ __ ] however you
want like you're a good looking young
coach it's not like the DMS ain't there
yeah like you can't that's true now
maybe he's like I'm gonna keep it close
and just [ __ ] around here and then in
the organization nobody will say
anything maybe
that's the definition of sitting where
you sleep right like literally yeah I
mean it just seems crazy yeah
yeah and apparently the guy that got to
replace him also [ __ ] he has like a DUI
maybe there's an assault in battery he
has some [ __ ] on him too yeah but this
story is so crazy in Boston it's like
that's true whatever it is it's some
[ __ ] that he has some character knocks
too but this story is so crazy we're
like whatever man let's just quiet
Sunday
another thing to your point the NBA by
all accounts is like a very small
tight-knit circle these stories
[ __ ] know the LeBron's mom
story from what I understand
[ __ ] knew
inside yeah the whole league knew yeah
you guys understand like a lot of these
guys been playing together since they're
12 years old yeah I mean they're like in
group chat like all this like when they
bark at one another and then they go how
can they be on the same team and it's
like they've been barking each other
since they're 13. yeah yeah AAU like
yeah they know did you hit up your boy
about this yeah see did he give you
anything inside
I found out who the real Affair was
before it came out and that was like
and I was like God damn like you went
after the [ __ ] head dudes yeah
assistant that's that's crazy that's
crazy yeah now the one thing I'm curious
about is if let's say like a higher
person yeah hooks up with a secretary or
a younger person in the thing yeah he
gets fired because he didn't disclose
nothing happens to him or her that's a
subordinate no like are they seen as a
liability like oh this like
hypothetically let's say there's a
secretary that hooked up with like three
CEOs in a row and they all keep getting
fired so that's the thing about the
that's the thing about like being
perceived as a victim like you can't
even fire her because she go I was
taking advantage of and I thought my job
was on the line even if that ain't
really what would happen does it if it
happens twice
oh she's been smashed by multiple people
let's say it happens two times let's say
this situation happens again with the
next head coach the same girl still
she's a victim bro they they held her
job over her they're gonna try to get
rid of her some other way yeah they're
gonna know yeah she's not gonna get any
uh what is it called uh advancement in
right of course you don't need to
promote you just can't outwardly fire
out of nowhere you're gonna want them to
quit lucky and it's not on the woman to
do this it's on both of them to do this
but like when you're looking at the
staff that you have and who you're gonna
reward like you want the girl who's
slapping dicks out of her [ __ ] face
right like you know what I mean like I
know it sounds crazy like it the dick
shouldn't be there but you also want the
girl going yo what the [ __ ] are you
doing like yeah yo we're in a finals run
you idiot yeah yeah like are you about
to [ __ ] this whole thing up for a dick
suck yeah like you could take this team
to the finals yeah like if I hear that I
got that chick on the staff you're the
coach
[Laughter]
he texts me and goes yo happy birthday
hope you have a great day I didn't
responded I was busy you know being
podcasting today emphasized it who's my
boy Jason
hey thanks for wishing Morgan happy
birthday dog this thankless piece of
[ __ ] I'm gonna get back to you and say
thanks so much now but you saw it yeah
you chose not to respond yeah I didn't
know but you saw it and you chose not to
write I didn't open it so much oh my bad
we were doing a podcast why did you
repost my my birthday story I don't like
to put it on my Instagram because it was
a Jewish thing
follows me yeah no I know I don't it's
just the whole thing I don't want people
to be like oh it's your birthday
yeah why'd he make it about him Jason
and why did Doug make it about it thank
you two juice tomato about them oh no oh
you guys did I'm saying it happy
birthday oh that's interesting
hey Circle him back on this yeah yeah
bumping this up yeah thanks for making a
little less happy say that to him thanks
for making a little less happy I knew I
had to do work on my birthday I didn't
respond to you what I don't know all
right this just happened I'm frustrated
yo just go who this
all right listen but we got to get out
of here man you guys guys we've been
watching the playground
we'll see you later have a good night
peace